hey guys today I'm using my streaming
setup to make this video I was like why
do I ever make videos here it's all
setup it's lit and I can do things like
this now yeah the green screen it's not
T but it'll do this article was freshly
posted this week iPhone 12 sizes
compared with the iPhone se 7 8 se 2 10
11 11 Pro at 11 Pro max so it looks like
Apple is planning on launching three
different sizes a 5 or a 6 1 2 6 7 so
you guys can see from this image here in
the lineup we've got our iPhone 12 the
50.4 and the iPhone 11 and 12 right here
which is basically going to be the same
size the 6 1 and the 6 7 the iPhone 12
big boy so what I'm wondering is are
they going to be calling at the iPhone
12 the iPhone 12 Pro and the iPhone 12
pro Mac's
again I'm gonna put a little YouTube
pool here so if you guys want to take
that I would love to hear what you guys
think the new iPhone is gonna be called
so these models are based on the leaks
that we've seen over the past few months
actually over a year I feel like it is
great to kind of see these all in a line
up so that you be able to kind of get a
better sense of what the size looks like
in comparison to some older versions so
this is super helpful analyst believes
iPhone 12 pricing will star $50 higher
even without earpods
or charger in the box this has been some
really big news a lot of people have
been talking about how the newest iPhone
might not come with a charger brick is
for me I mean kind of sucks because I
actually do love having the charger
brick but in reality I hardly ever use
that charger brick to charge my iPhone I
use it to charge pretty much everything
else usually all this time I have been
waiting and hoping and wishing for the
iPhone to finally be USBC so most likely
it will still have a port to be able to
charge with but will it come with a
brick no will it come with a cable I
would imagine it would still at least
come with a cable but no ear pods no
charging brick and still 50 dollars more
so I guess most of the recent news
because a lot of the specs and of the
things that have been linked previously
the one thing that is
kind of been held a little bit closer
has been the prices but this is sort of
what the lineup is saying the five point
four inches 649 the six point one is 749
a 6.1 inch 12 Pro would be $9.99 and the
six point seven inch 12 purl max would
be 1099 so it does seem like these are
the same naming conventions as the
previous iPhone which I think would
actually make sense because I feel like
they finally kind of have a name that
fits it makes sense for a while it was
getting incredibly confusing I feel like
we had the iPhone 10 are maybe iPhone 10
but yet people kept calling it the X
something like this makes sense you'll
have two different sizes of the iPhone
12 and you'll have two sizes of the pro
that just makes too much sense that I
feel like they're probably they're gonna
change it because it makes too much
sense this is funny because they believe
that the price will be accepted by
consumers and will not affect demand but
the move would generate controversy
nonetheless of the earpods and wall
charger are removed for the box as
rumored I have another question for you
guys do you actually use the earpods
or do you use something different
because I have not used a set of the
earpods
since the air plots came out even then I
feel like I never really use them we do
use a very old version of the earpods
with a 3.5 millimeter headphone jack for
some reason those are Tyler's favorite
headphones to use when we're monitoring
audio well the new ones are lightning
cable specific so you can't use those
with anything else so along that same
prediction they're saying the 6.1 inch
iPhone would likely start at $7.99 or
849 so if you would want to stick with
the same display size as the iPhone 11
you could be facing a larger $100 to
$150 price increase my phones are
expensive they are very expensive when
you start going up to these higher end
models but when I think about the amount
that I use this phone for so many things
on a daily basis when I basically run my
entire company from this I know it's
weird to say that I'm a company but I am
strange I know if I had nothing else I
could exist with just this might not be
able to do all of the things that I've
still been doing but I can still do it I
could do live streams I could edit video
I could record audio really can do
everything on this that is a pretty big
price increase
and the fact that 5g isn't really
everywhere yet that is kind of a
hinderance especially since I haven't
gone anywhere in months I've just been
sitting here in the house bored that's
one thing I haven't been I haven't been
bored in the house or actually I have a
little bit but now that I have all these
new hobbies I'm gonna get a drum set
because I want to learn to play the
drums my sister I have a podcast now
I've started live-streaming video games
I've started playing call of duty again
this porn team has definitely had a lot
of ups and downs probably more downs but
I feel like a lot of us have tried to
make the best out of the situation so
for you guys has anything good actually
come out of quarantine for you I would
love to hear about it in the comments
below and if nothing good has happened
I'd also like to hear about that because
I feel like you're not alone
and we should all discuss see we've
house if we got here oh this is pretty
cool so they saw in the announcement
that they were talking about the new
clips app which is basically a mini
little app that's under ten megabytes
that you'll be able to download just by
scanning a QR code but this is kind of
cool code payments so you can now use
Apple pay to make payments with QR codes
you guys would probably use venmo before
and it's really great because they have
a little QR code that you can scan and
then pay someone does right here
references bound in the iOS 14 code
reveal that Apple is working on a new
method for letting users make payments
with Apple pay by scanning in QR that's
a good basic wait what we just said
I'm just rereading it don't you - too
bad the one thing that is gonna be kind
of interesting that a lot of people have
been discussing and this has been a
problem throughout this entire year is
the supply and demand of parts to make
things there's been a lot of holdup in
production because things are made
overseas and we're not able to actually
get those parts to complete projects so
this isn't just an iPhone specific thing
this is pretty much a worldwide issue
because of the pandemic although at
least one model might not become
available to order until October or
November I feel like this is a very
realistic thing that could happen I mean
it's going to be interesting
to see how they even reveal the iPhone
because still people aren't traveling
every single event has been canceled
this year I think a lot of companies
have been doing a really great job of
stepping up their game and really trying
to make these virtual environments and
press releases and press announcements
even extra-special because the fact that
people are actually able to go there and
see the things in person like we used to
I'm gonna miss it so much and I think
Apple has been doing a great job of sort
of pushing that envelope and showing
people with what they did with WWDC that
it is possible to do an incredible
keynote and still kind of make people
feel like they were there and a part of
it this design I think looks really good
this is what I hope the iPhone Falls
looks like I like the fact that they
kind of went back to sort of the squared
edges I love the way that these four
cameras are laid out I'm assuming that
that fourth one is probably the lidar
sensor
what is this mask do I need to buy this
now this is crazy I mean I'm a little
bit hard of hearing and I never realized
until people were wearing masks how much
I rely on reading people's lips to be
able to understand what they're saying
so I can only imagine how hard this is
for a lot of people when they solely
rely on being able to read lips so this
is really I mean this looks ridiculous
but okay that's but that's a little much
we don't need that but having this clear
opening it looks really silly but this
is incredibly helpful
it's done it's so good on my runs so
here's some of the specs based on leaks
for the iPhone 12 12 max 12 Pro and 12
Pro max the two lower end models will be
OLED where the higher end will be the
XDR OLED super Retina the processor a 14
biotic across all models four gigs of
ram in the lower end six gigs in the
higher end and it looks like they're
only going to be going up to 512 I kind
of think they might do a one terabyte
phone I'm hoping because I've filled up
my phone new phones typically launched
in September multiple reports point to a
delay
will there be a delay or will there not
oh wow look at this pink this is nice
and like a nice salmon I love this I
love this squared look I'm so into it I
hope that they do this I really hope
they do oh wow look at this Oh some
schematics this was back in April I've
not been doing much research on my
iPhone 12 rumors because I've been
playing a lot of animal crossing in Call
of Duty can you double base play that
huh
yeah have you seen anything so talented
where you to think did sort of an ombre
color like that midnight blue hue that
green looks really good I love having
the silver iPhone again but it's been
it's been really great what a great look
you you look good Apple could ditch
ports altogether and skip over USB see I
really think it's possible like if
anybody is going to completely ditch
having any type of way to plug in their
phone it's gonna be Apple
here's another leak with the potential
lidar camera this is a great article
tom's guide hello here's a list of 120
Hertz phones for 2020 are we missing any
I'm excited to check out the new note 20
plus very excited iPhone 12 touch ID in
display at least one model of the iPhone
12 could offer an under display
ultrasonic fingerprint sensor which
would bring touch ID back after using
the iPhone se doing a review of that
phone I have missed the fingerprint
sensor so much mostly because now
everybody's wearing masks and if you're
not wearing masks I know where you can
get a really good one yeah what was I
looking I've lost my page as
possible.the 2021 iPhones could feature
both face ID and touch ID that mean we'd
have to wait until next year the teeth I
do feel like the touch ID on this latest
phone is probably not actually going to
be a reality I mean maybe it's something
that they can throw together quickly but
I feel like it's not gonna be up to
apple's standards if they were to
release it right now because it looks
like this is something they probably
planned on releasing in the iPhone 13
it's probably not ready but due to the
current climate of
everything that is happening right now
the fact that having that fingerprint
sensor would be will be actually pretty
pretty huge I mean I like face ID but it
isn't freaking work when you're wearing
a mask so what's the point so I guess
that is where we currently are at with
iPhone 12 rumors and some of the things
that I've read online I'll put links to
all of the articles that I talked about
in the description if you guys want to
check those out and read some more in
depth this was really fun I have missed
making these types of little sit-down
videos here and I'm so excited to have
this little streaming setup if you guys
haven't already go check out my twitch
channel twitch comm /i justine my
channel over there on twitch is like 13
years old when I think about that it's
really crazy but I'm having so much fun
over there doing some live streaming of
games mostly animal crossing but
sometimes mariokart and a little bit of
Call of Duty so I gotta check it out if
you get a chance and that's it you guys
haven't subscribed to my youtube channel
make sure you hit that subscribe button
hit the bell and you'll be notified when
I post a new video I hope you guys are
all doing well staying safe out there
wear a mask and do whatever it is that
you're doing to pass the time we'll see
you later bye
[Music]